This lecture is about link analysis for
web search.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about web search.
And particularly focusing on how to do
link analysis and use the results to
improve search.
The main topic of this lecture is to
look at the ranking algorithms for web
search.
In the previous lecture we talked about
how to create index now that we have
got index.
We want to see how we can improve
ranking of pages.
Our standard IR models can be also
applied here.
In fact they are important building
blocks for improvement for supporting
web search, but they aren't sufficient
and mainly for the following reasons.
First, on the web we tend to have very
different information needs.
For example, people might search for a
web page or entry page and this is
different from the traditional library
search where people are primarily
interested in collecting literature
information.
So this kind of query is often called
navigational queries.
The purpose is to navigate into a
particular target page.
So for such queries we might benefit
from using link information.
Secondly, documents have additional
information and on the web web pages
are well format.
There are a lot of other clues such as
the layout, title or link information.
Again, so this has provided the
opportunity to use extra context
information.
Of the document to improve scoring and
finally information quality varies a
lot, so that means we have to consider
many factors to improve the ranking
algorithm.
This would give us a more robust way to
rank the pages, making it harder for
any spammer to just manipulate the one
signal to improve the ranking of a page.
So as a result, people have made a
number of major extensions to the
ranking algorithms.
One line is to exploit links to improve
scoring.
And that's the main topic of this
lecture.
People have also proposed algorithms to
exploit the large scale
implicit feedback information in the
form of click throughs, and that's of
course in the category of feedback
techniques. And machine learning is
often used there. In general in web
search the ranking algorithms are based on
machine learning algorithms to combine
all kinds of features.
Many of them are based on the standard
visual models such as BM25 that we
talked about.
Or query likelihood to score different
parts of documents or to provide
additional features based on content
matching, but link information is also
very useful so they provide additional
scoring.
Signals.
So let's look at links in more detail
on the web.
So this is a snapshot of some part of the
web and say so we can see there are
many links that link the different
pages together, and in this case you
can also look at the center here.
There is a description of a link that's
pointing to the document on the right
side.
Now this description text is called
anchor text.
Now if you think about the this text, it's
actually quite a useful because it
provides some extra description of that
page being pointed to.
So for example, if someone wants to
bookmark Amazon.com, front page the
person might say.
The biggest online bookstore and then
with the link to Amazon.
Right, so the description here actually
is very similar to what the user will
type in the query box when they are
looking for such a page, and that's why
it's very useful for ranking pages.
Suppose someone types in query like
online bookstore or fixed online
bookstore.
The query would match this anchor text.
In the page.
Here and then, this actually provides
evidence for matching the page that's
being pointed to.
That is the Amazon entry page.
So if you match the anchor text that
describes a link to a page, actually
that provides good evidence for the
relevance of the page being pointed to,
so anchor text is very useful.
If you look at the bottom part of this
picture you can also see there are some
patterns of links, and these links
might indicate the utility of a
document.
So for example on the right side you
can see this page has received, many
in links.
That means many other pages are
pointing to this page and this shows
that this page is quite useful.
On the left side you can see, this is another
page that points to many other pages,
so this is a directory page that
would allow you to actually see a lot
of other pages.
So we can call the first case authority
page and the second case half page.
This means the link information can
help in two ways.
One is to provide extra text for matching
and the other is to provide some
additional scores for the web pages to
characterize how likely a pages have,
how likely a pages authority.
So people then of course proposed
ideas to leverage these in this link
information.
Now Google's Pagerank, which was the
main technique that they used in early
days, is a good example and that is an
algorithm to capture page popularity,
basically to score authority.
So the intuition's here are links are
just like a citations in the
literature.
Think about one page pointing to
another page.
This is very similar to one paper
citing another paper.
So of course, then if a page is cited
often, then we can assume this page to
be more useful, in general.
So that's a very good intuition.
Now Pagerank is essentially to take
advantage of this intuition to
implement it with the principled
approach.
Intuitively, it's essentially doing
citation counting or in link counting.
It just improves this simple idea in
two ways.
One is it would consider indirect
citations.
So that means you don't just look at
the how many in links you have.
You also look at the what are those
pages that are pointing to you.
If those pages themselves have a lot of
in links, well that means a lot.
In some sense you will get some credit
from them.
But, if those pages that are
pointing to you are not being pointed
to by other pages, they themselves
don't have many in links then, well, you
don't get that much credit.
So that's the idea of getting
indirected citation.
Alright you can also understand this idea
by looking at again the research
papers.
If you're cited by let's say 10 papers
and those 10 papers are just workshop
papers and or some papers that are not
very influential, right?
So although you get 10 in links and
that's not as good as if you were cited
by 10 papers that themselves have
attracted a lot of other citations.
So this is.
A case where we would like to consider
indirect links and Pagerank does
that.
The other idea is it's going to smooth
the citations or assume that basically
every page is having a non zero pseudo
citation count.
Essentially we're trying to imagine
there are many virtual links that will
link all the pages together so that you
actually get pseudo citations from
everyone.
The reason why they want to do that is
this would allow them to solve the
problem elegantly with.
Linear algebra technique.
So.
I think maybe the best way to
understand the page rank is through.
Think of this as do computer
the probability of random surfer, visiting
every web page.